let's go to our next caller from the 9 1
0 area code
go ahead are you doing good is this my
name is Barry
I'm calling from North Carolina I've
talked to you before and you know due to
time restraints I've never got to really
explain ourselves but it's kind of you
know pertaining to that and it pertains
to the legitimacy of the president okay
and shouldn't we be moving forward with
something to be undoing anything done
under a legitimate president because of
anything that's later found out maybe
they tampered with voting or right yeah
under impeachment is one thing but
that's just basically moving on and
everything he's put in place just taking
place okay so yes with this let me ask
you this here's the thing in order to
undo actions on the basis of a
presidency being illegitimate you first
have to have a determination legally
speaking that the presidency is
illegitimate so how we don't have that
right now so how can we undo stuff on
that basis right what we don't know the
extent of the voter tampering the
collusion we don't know but I would
think that we would you know say for
example the Supreme Court no Gorsuch if
the presidency is illegitimate isn't his
appointment to Supreme Court
illegitimate listen I like the line of
reasoning you're using which is of
course if this if the person making the
decisions shouldn't have been making
decisions in the purse first place of
course you call into question those
decisions but what I'm telling you is
who's gonna do anything right now when
we've had no determination of that at
this point you've got a conservative
majority and on the Supreme Court you
have a Republican majority in
governorships
you have Republicans controlling the
house as well as the Senate I mean it's
it's a I agree with the logic of what
you're saying but it's just it's just
not going to happen well nobody's
talking about it I mean even you know
the liberal the left the right the
Democratic Republicans independent
nobody's talking about protecting our
kind
against legitimacy yeah I mean here's
the thing what I hear and understand and
share your frustration but I think part
of the reason it's not being talked
about is that it would be futile at this
point until you have a full
determination of illegitimate see you
you can't use that possible illegitimate
see in order to do or undo anything you
know what I mean it just it wouldn't go
anywhere I just seem like that seems
like part of you know I know it's never
happened before but it seems like if
somebody is put in a position where they
should have been in then everything that
they do should be undone and that just
seems like common sense and that it's
absolutely not
it's absolutely common sense and it's a
concern but it's just it at this time it
wouldn't go anywhere like if an
illegitimate president starts a war what
happens how do you undo your or cannot
do it a lot of the stuff can't literally
be undone in the sort of executive
orders can be easily undone I mean there
could be a law or even an executive
order that says if if a presence is
found to be impeached or that you know
or even resigned under impeachment you
know an experiment teach me than all
executive orders and all appointments
should be undone I mean hey listen I I'm
not telling you that you're you're
thinking crazy
i I just um what I'm saying is there's a
practical reason why we're not hearing a
lot of discussion about that there and I
gotta go I appreciate the call though
yeah thank you all right pleasure that's
it for this week we will take calls
again next week thanks to everybody who
called in sorry to the people that are
on hold that we didn't get to but we
will get to you again